5 25 on your monday morning what's
driving you crazy how about more cone
related headaches on the 215 around the
95. let's go
centennial bowling
the north and eastbound side of the
western 215 beltway being taken down to
one lane
anywhere from around lone mountain all
the way around the curve to the 95 in
the centennial bowl from nine each night
until around daylight and over the next
few weeks you should be ready for the
same thing going the other way
clark county says none of the work
should be a daytime problem and you'll
have plenty of time to get used to the
overnight lane reductions they're
scheduled to last until maybe may that's
nine months part of the widening the
beltway project from two to three lanes
in the area
and if it makes it feel any better the
county's leaving you playing a little
bit of a guessing game with the t's that
there will be times during the project
with no
overnight lane restrictions but who
knows when that's going to be buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 8newsnow.com